Jay Sekulow is an attorney for President
Trump
good morning Jay good morning thanks for
having me let me ask you federal law
states that it is a crime for any
foreigner to contribute or donate money
or some other thing of value in
connection with an American election did
Donald Trump jr. break the law he did
not the meeting that took place there's
nothing illegal about it there was not a
violation of the law no illegality and
the statute you're quoting from the the
FEC statutes are not criminal statutes
but there's not a that is not a
violation that the meeting that took
place in the context and by the way I'm
not the only lawyer that's saying this
most legal scholars are saying this and
it's certainly in you look at the law as
it is written as it's applied there was
not a violation of the law here in fact
meetings like this on opposition
research is in are not uncommon even in
United the government aspect is raised a
lot of interest obviously we're talking
about it this morning but you had the
situation with the Ukrainian government
providing information to the Hillary
Clinton campaign to the DNC again the
illegality issue is was there a
violation of law in the conduct of this
meeting and what took place in the
answer is no would you at least agree or
admit that the optics here do not look
good
you say it's not illegal but he's
meeting with afoot what he believes is a
foreign a person from Russia who says
listen I have some information that
could help your dad's campaign would you
agree the optics on that do not look
good for Donald Trump jr. or the Trump
campaign well you're asking about
atmospherics and how did the
atmospherics looks but let's we're gonna
look at atmospherics let's put ourselves
back in to where we were in time this is
in the middle of the election for the
presidency of the United States this is
in the full battle of the electoral
moment right hundreds of meetings taking
place teams are working on both sides
Republicans Democrats 18 hours 20-hour
days this is one meeting out of hundreds
of meetings that took place on a whole
variety of topics with both campaigns so
when you put it in that atmospheric it
was rather unremarkable in the sense
that nothing transpired
nothing illegal took place so you're
asking the atmospheric question but
remember this also the whole Russia
discussion this wasn't a significant
discussion at the time the Russia
involvement and you know the the other
thing that seems to get lost in this and
I've said this before you know there's
all this concern about Russia all the
reports have indicated that President
Obama was aware of Russia attempts at
engagement and they did nothing about it
so here you have a situation where what
took place per those emails that were
released was not a violation of the law
knowing illegalities there and I think
that's where as a look as a lawyer as
the president's lawyer that's what I
have to look at Jay we're not just
talking about atmospherics we're talking
about ethics here and there was a long
lead-up to this meeting taking place a
discussion between Donald Trump jr. and
the folks trying to coordinate it so it
wasn't just 20 minutes out of one long
day there was a long procession
beforehand well you know look at the
email exchanges these are quickie minute
yeah okay right he put him out there and
the fact is if you look at this rapid
succession of emails that takes place
over a number of days for a meeting
that lasted 20 minutes so what you have
is a set up to a meeting a meeting that
takes place by the way no information
exchanged it ended up not even being on
the pretext of what was supposed to be
about it ended up being about all Majin
ski act in the issue of Russian adoption
so the end result well I mean that's
what she said but let me let me say
something here I'm here also as the
president United States that's why I'm
here I'm the president's lawyer one of
the president's lawyers and I want to be
very clear in something the president
was not aware of this meeting did not
attend this meeting and was only very
recently made aware of this email in
fact he did not read the email but was
not provided to him until we saw it
yesterday when you all saw it can you
clarify and make clear today are there
any other meetings with Russian
government officials that have not yet
been disclosed look Donald Trump jr.
said he met with a lot of people he
could have met with Russians and other
people all right Jay Sekulow
thank you so much for joining us thanks
for having me